with Avengers infinity war and Avengers
endgame the last remnants of the walls
dividing the separate regions of the MCU
were finally obliterated once and for
all now phase four of the MCU is just
around the corner and we've got a wish
list of the mashups we're most hoping to
see Sam Wilson recently seen taking up
cap shield at the end of Avengers end
game will be co-headlining the Disney
Plus Series the Falcon and the Winter
Soldier with Sebastian Stan's Bucky
Barnes although Sam has shown up in
three Avengers movies and briefly an
ant-man he's primarily been a Captain
America character and hasn't interacted
much with many of the MCU sprawling
roster of heroes while there's no
shortage of existing characters Sam
hasn't yet met the one we'd most like to
see him interact with is Carol Danvers
Sam will be in the market for a new best
friend after losing Steve to the Past
and end game and we get the feeling
Carol has been a little personally
unmoored ever since losing and regaining
her memories in Captain Marvel they
could each choose a new shoulder to lean
on and we can see their personalities
playing well off of one another in
addition to their shared military
background
Sam's experience running a support group
for veterans may be just what carol
needs to help unpack all she's been
through what's more their shared
experience of losing their best friends
may help them understand one another in
a unique and interesting way although
one division has confirmed that ant-man
and the wasps FBI agent Jimmy woo will
be appearing in some capacity we have no
idea what sort of role he'll be playing
in the mind-bending tale whan division
is one of the least predictable of the
Disney Plus shows since we've been told
that it'll take place after the events
of Avengers endgame but also apparently
in the 1950s as such it's entirely
possible that some characters may exist
in one time period or reality and not in
others meaning that there's no guarantee
that Wanda or vision will actually
interact with every member of the show's
cast however we really hope that we get
to see what happens when Jimmy
encounters vision for the first time
it's not just that we want each of them
to make a good friend although that's
part of it
wandah vision has always seemed kind of
isolated and Jimmy came across as pretty
lonely an ant-man did you want to grab
Tennyson
I mean I'm free we'd love nothing more
than to see the two of them buddy up and
fill that bestie shaped hole in each
other's lives but also given Jimmy's
interest in Scotts close-up magic tricks
we expect him to be blown away by
visions abilities and really his entire
half technological half magical
existence the ending of Doctor Strange
hold a first for an MCU movie lamed
groundwork for a character who had been
an ally throughout the entire film to
become a villain in the next one
so although Baron Mordo hasn't been
confirmed to appear in phase four it
would be surprising if he didn't show up
again in fact we think Wan Division
would be a great and unexpected place to
bring him back
the rigidly principled Mordo spent most
of dr. strange growing increasingly
uncomfortable with the way that both
strange and the ancient one used magic
so we can't imagine he'll react well to
Wanda Maximoff under reality altering
powers it would be a fascinating way to
tie the worlds of Wanda vision and
Doctor Strange together an event which
has already been confirmed to happen one
way or another perhaps Wanda creates
some sort of alternate reality where
vision is alive splitting open the
multiverse and drawing mortos attention
leading directly into the events of
Doctor Strange in the multiverse of
madness or maybe Mordo is already well
on his way down a dark path and Wanda is
the one who discovers it prompting her
to seek help from dr. strange while the
possibilities for who could make a
surprise appearance and Loki are nearly
endless another name at the top of our
list is dr. Strange's the ancient one
who surprised audiences by showing up an
Avengers end game she'd be the perfect
one for Loki to meet up with as he skips
through time especially if he has an
infinity stone in tow in addition to
providing some much-needed exposition on
how Loki's adventures may muddy up the
larger timeline the ancient one also has
the unique ability to see alternate
futures that means that although Loki
will have no knowledge of his character
growth in phases two
three of the MCU she very well could
perhaps a meeting with the ancient one
will be exactly what Loki needs in order
to help him become a better version of
himself putting him on the path to
becoming the kind of person he was at
the beginning of infinity war along with
the surprise announcement that Juan
Division would be bringing back Jimmy
woo came the equally shocking revelation
that the series would also be pulling in
the character of Darcy Lewis from the
first to Thor movies Darcy was
astrophysicist Jane Foster's intern
although her political science major
didn't always make her the best fit for
Jane's scientific theorizing and
experimentation like Jane Darcy didn't
appear in Thor Ragnarok but now it
appears she'll be returning for Wanda
vision although we have no idea how or
why since one division is reported to
lead directly into Doctor Strange in the
multiverse of madness we are crossing
our fingers that Darcy will be coming
along for the ride to when and if she
does help she'll have a chance to get to
know Wong Strange's long-suffering
friend and instructor in the mystic arts
considering how Darcy always reacted to
Thor's magic adjacent abilities we
suspect her reactions to actual magic
would be a comedic goldmine plus Wong
and Darcy both know how it feels to be
relegated to the sidekick and we imagine
that Darcy's blunt honesty and abundant
eccentricities will provide an
entertaining contrast to Wong's deadpan
demeanor and constant exasperation maybe
they can go out for sandwiches together
I wouldn't say no to a 2 now although
the spider-man movies already contain
the vast majority of the teenage
characters in the MCU Peter hasn't yet
come face to face with that other Marvel
wunderkind wakanda's princess and chief
innovator Cherie the two were briefly in
the same place at the same time during
avengers endgame but as far as we know
they never interacted all that could
change in the MCU spider-man 3 which
will pick up on the heels of that doozy
of a cliffhanger at the end of
spider-man far from home maybe Peter
goes into hiding after his secret
identity is revealed and winds up
seeking aid from the people of Wakanda
will accept any number of scenarios as
long as it brings the two of the MCU
greatest young scientific minds together
for a few scenes the opening of Avengers
endgame gave us a pairing we never
really expected to see as Tony Stark and
nebula made their way laborious ly back
to earth after finding themselves the
only survivors on Titan following the
snap the two proved to have a delightful
dynamic and the quiet scenes of the two
of them together were surprisingly
poignant nebula then went on to play one
of the most important roles in endgame
and ended the film back aboard the
benatar with the rest of the guardians
of the galaxy
- Gamora + Thor assuming they're still
all traveling the stars together as the
as guardians of the galaxy at the
beginning of Thor love and thunder we
hope that nebula gets a chance to
interact with Korg Korg is still on
earth at the end of endgame and as part
of the new Asgard settlement over which
Valkyrie rules is king but we know both
characters are already confirmed for
love and thunder while we have no such
confirmation for nebula or the other
guardians we wouldn't be surprised if
the crew of the benatar appears for at
least part of the film even if it's just
a drop throw off before heading back out
again if they do we're crossing our
fingers for some scenes between the
aggressively self-serious nebula and the
gentle-hearted unflappable chord we
can't imagine what they talk about but
it would surely be thoroughly
entertaining maybe they can bond about
how much they hate their father figures
oh well I tried to start a revolution
but didn't print enough pamphlets so
hardly anyone turned up except for my
mum and her boyfriend who I hate Marvel
and director Taika Waititi ruthlessly
cleaned house for thor ragnarok killing
off half of the supporting Asgardian
characters from the previous films and
cutting the earthbound characters out of
the story entirely however one
established Thor character whose fate is
still up in the air following the events
of Ragnarok infinity war and end gained
his lady SIF the character was last seen
on the big screen delivering the reality
stone to the collector at the end of
Thor the dark world before appearing in
a couple of episodes of agents of shield
whether or not SIF was blipped by Thanos
an infinity war she should be alive by
the time love and thunder rolls around
and we're ready for her to return to the
MCU as
especially because we really want to see
what happens when SIF and Valkyrie
finally meet one another it's high time
that the Thor movies allowed more than
one powerful female warrior on the
Thunder gods team at a time and we
imagine that these two will really hit
it off
Tessa Thompson has said that Valkyrie
will be in search of her queen and
Alexander has volunteered herself for
the role on Twitter whether or not a
romantic relationship is in the cards
for the two Asgardian warriors we still
expect some sparks to fly when they
finally come together
although Bruce Banner and Jane Foster
are both gifted scientists who have
played major roles in previous Thor
movies the paths have never crossed by
the time Bruce smashed his way into Thor
Ragnarok Jane and Thor had broken up and
we thought she'd vanished from the MCU
for good but now that we know Jane is
returning for Thor love and thunder were
anxious for Bruce to make a return
appearance as well while earlier Thor
movies have allowed Jane to bounce her
scientific ideas off Erik Selvig we've
loved a film in which she's allowed to
riff about quantum physics with Bruce
instead especially if he's in his big
green form with Tony Stark gone Bruce
could use a new partner to talk shop
with and we can't think of a better
person to speak the strange language of
science meets superheroes than Jane
Foster
although Clint Barton and Bucky Barnes
have both been around the MCU since
phase 1 and even fought on the same team
and Captain America Civil War we still
haven't seen the two actually interact
with one another
it's an odd oversight especially
considering that both were trained by
branches of the same organization have a
super spy background and know what it
feels like to have their minds taken
over by an external force so while we
still have no idea how much the Disney
Plus shows will crossover with one
another our hope is that the Hawkeye
series will finally bring the archer and
the Winter Soldier together
although Bucky and Clint have shared a
lot in common in the past they've never
been more alike than they are in the
post endgame MCU Clint's spent five
years before the time heist tracking
down and killing people who while they
want entirely innocent likely didn't
deserve the Fate he meted out to them by
the time he found himself on Boromir
Clint felt significant remorse for the
harm he had done no character in the
see you is better poised to understand
what it feels like than Bucky Barnes who
spent seventy years as a brainwashed
Hydra assassin if the Falcon and the
Winter Soldier can work in a crossover
with Hawkeye we expect these two will
have a lot to discuss
as long as Bucky cares more than Black
Panther did when he and Clint finally
met we haven't met yet check out one of
our newest videos right here plus even
more looper videos about your favorite
Marvel movies are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and hit the belt
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you
[Music]